I want to talk about your starting point
as a storyteller for a movie like this
do you start with a situation do you
start with a character do you start with
an image and is it always the same for
every movie and what was the inception
for this story itself it very slightly
for each film this is my fourth film and
I've started to get a handle on my
process I think at this point I always
write on two tracks usually I take a
genre track but really it's it's just
things about plot you know where the
movie's going what's happening what
blows up these kinds of questions and
that came very quickly on this film in
fact that came first I was struck by the
image of two guys in a very fast car
driving down a rural back road in the
south at night that was the first image
and that's usually how it starts that's
how it started with take shelter shotgun
stories my first film was a little
different but you know I got pretty far
along in the trajectory of the story
before knowing really what the film was
about and I've done this enough times
now I knew that if my films were were at
all successful they were successful in
and one thing which is trying to
transfer an emotion over to the audience
an emotion that is very personal to me
oddly enough I think a lot of times we
sit down as riders to try and make
Universal films universal stories and it
seems to me from the analysis of four
films now the best way to make something
Universal is to make it very specific
make it very specific to your own life
and and in this case I was developing
this kind of silly sci-fi chase movie
idea Wow I was in the throes of the
first year fatherhood and about eight
months in to my son's life he had a
febrile seizure which is the body's
reaction to a spiking fever it doesn't
have long lasting effects but it was
quite terrifying my wife and I thought
he was
dime and it it in this first year of
fatherhood where you're sleep deprived
and your social life is changing and all
these things it was like dunking my head
in cold water and i woke up very very
quickly to this reality that this boy
could be taken away from me he could die
and i was racked with fear from that and
i started to try and figure out why am I
here as a parent if I can't control his
environment if I can't keep him safe and
if you extrapolate that further and say
I can't control who he becomes why am I
here and I started to realize I think as
a parent you're just you're constantly
trying to define who your child is you
try not to project who you want them to
be don't put your point of view on them
you just want to try and define who they
are for themselves and as they grow you
redefine that and that became the really
the basis for Mike Shannon's character
through the whole film he has no clue of
what his son's doing or where he's going
he's just trying to figure it out and
have faith in the idea that he's going
someplace he should how do you balance
those incredibly strong emotions with
the genre in which you're working and
also the idea that and you've said this
before that you don't want to be a slave
to plot in fact you've said I think plot
is overrated so how do you go about
constructing a movie that's going to be
that's going to serve those emotions
that you feel very strongly about work
in the style in which you like to write
or make movies and also fit in the
conventions of what some people might
expect this movie to do or become right
the more I do this the more complex that
gets you know but because you can break
it into a few different things you can
break it into you know subverting genre
and you can you can talk about narrative
exposition and my desire to remove it at
all costs but I think the key thing to
talk about is just character behavior
you know in a screenplay you have two
things you have lines of action and
to dialogue and that's it and in the
lines of action you say the character
walks in sits down picks up his water
you just explain what he does it makes
no sense to say he walks in sits down
picks up his water because his mother
beat him when he was a kid you that
would be stupid why would you include
that because no one's going to see that
so why would you ever include that in
the dialogue I think there's a myth that
dialogue is somehow outside of behavior
it's the exact same and so if you've
made a rule for yourself as a writer
which I have which is to treat dialogue
strictly as behavior then you have to
look at the the situations that the
characters are in in these scenes and
you have to try and be as honest as you
can we very rarely save for press tours
say exactly what we want we're very very
they're very few times where this
calculated and we've had these things
thought out we usually speak in subtext
I'm going to talk about your actors in a
minute but I want to talk about your
collaborators because you are a writer
director and you have written and
directed all of your movies but there's
also a team around you that is key and
that team includes your cinematographer
Adam stone your production designer Chad
Keith on this film your composure David
Wingo and your producer Sarah green and
Brian Kavanaugh Jones so even though you
are the writer-director can you talk
about how you work with this group and
why they are so essential to what you're
able to do yeah a quick speech on the
front of it it's not just false humility
here you know people throw out the word
I'll tour and everything else and yeah
it's flattering anyone that's actually
been involved in the making of a film
knows that it pretty much everybody in
this room it's an absolute lie you know
to say this is a jeff nichols film
that's why i've never taken a possessory
credit to be honest because it's it's
false it's fiction if you took David
wingo my composure out of the equation
my films would feel differently if you
took Adam stone out of the equation my
films would feel differently so when
people say well that's a jeff nichols
film what they're really talking about
is this group of people and I I'd I mean
that through and through and through you
know I've been really lucky to slowly be
able to be
together a team that I trust and that
know me for who I am oh it's just like
you're in this really amazing band and
and you can look at each other's
performances and just say we're all in
sync we're all in rhythm we're all on
the same page and your lead vocalist is
Michael Shannon pretty much right I
assume you wrote is actually a lead
vocalist okay you write for him you
write with him how do you collaborate
with him and how did you find Jordan
labor her us your young boy you know
mike is Mike's one of the greatest
actors in the world period and I've
worked with some amazing actors you know
I worked with Matthew McConaughey i
worked with Jessica Chastain and and
Mike and I have a very unique
relationship we we don't talk very much
we don't really try and go into
backstory or anything else beyond the
necessities to pull off a scene we just
identify with one another and I think we
identify with with these types of
characters that I'm writing and I think
he makes me a better writer I think if
I've stated that there's you know a
narrative experiment that I'm attempting
with these films of trying to remove
exposition anything unnecessary you can
partly do that because you know Mike
Shannon is going to be there to catch
you if you fall in between the lines
Mike Shannon is going to be emitting
this information from his pores and and
that's a that's a pretty big safety net
as a filmmaker for Jaden you know I
typically recoil when I hear the term
child actor you know I was very lucky in
this film mud that I made to find these
two boys that felt like they almost just
walked out of the woods in fact one did
actually walk out of the woods but um
and it was my natural instinct to start
that casting process again you know we
saw the thousand kids throughout the
southwest and southeast and I met a ton
of them and I met some really great kids
and I met some kids that could could
even handle the lines here and there
you know and this was this was a
dangerous age though because this eight
there's a big difference between 8 and
13 and obviously now that you have seen
the film there's a point when when this
boy is supposed to become aware of his
place in the universe that's a very hard
thing to act that's a very hard thing to
pretend and when I met Jaden who came to
me through CAA I had like a 10 minute
meeting with him in Austin he came to
see me and I was immediately struck by
how aware he was of the situation we
were in he's obviously one of these
hyper intelligent kids but it wasn't
that he was performing he wasn't tap
dancing for me he just knew where he was
at and what what the what the score was
and you could see it in his eyes and I
knew that if he had that capacity that I
could mute him in the first half of film
stick his nose in a comic book not given
many lines and then when I turned him on
he'd be there for me and and I I think
it works let me ask you this last
question the name of the movie is
probably inspired by the 1930s or
earlier song leadbelly covered it
Creedence covered it I think Van
Morrison covered it is this a song you
heard growing up that stuck with you is
that the lyric that made you want to
name your movie after it yeah to be
honest it's not it's not as intelligent
an answer as it should be I just thought
was badass you know I I grew up listen
to this song grip listen to credence and
you know I actually had to go back and
discover the Leadbelly version but
that's when I was going through an alan
lomax period anyway but like you know
like i said i had this first image these
two guys in a car driving fast down a
rural southern road at night and very
quickly after that i thought i could
call it Midnight Special it just seemed
to evoke the tone in the mood that I was
going to go after you know the colors
and also just the feeling of a late
night drive-in movie you know that felt
fun to me that felt like something I
wanted to spend a few years of my life
working on it was a good couple hours to
watch jeff nichols thank you
thank you all for eyes for them now we
know